non
bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo à
bruxelles aujourd'hui un invité
exceptionnel
martin schulz le président du parlement
européen
et cette semaine reportage en tunisie où
un projet de chaîne de télé pour
promouvoir la condition des femmes dans
les pays du printemps arabe a vu le jour
avec des soutiens européens mais tout de
suite avec martin schulz nous allons
évoquer les dossiers chauds qui inquiète
l'europe
on commence bien sûr par le cas
chypriote plus d'argent la plupart des
distributeurs de billets à chypre sont
vides
l'activité des convoyeurs de fonds a été
suspendue conséquence du plan de
sauvetage européen accordé au pays en
échange de l'imposition d'une taxe sur
les dépôts bancaires françaises c'est
sans doute injuste mais c'est une
solution mais alice je suis venu retirer
de l'argent mais tous les retraits ont
été bloqués la situation est tragique
les milliards d'euros donnés par l'union
européenne ne règle pas les problèmes de
chiffres la population rejette le plan
de sauvetage et la proposition de taxer
les déposants ne passe pas dans le pays
ils veulent nous vider les poches c'est
le cri de colère de ce travailleur à la
mairie de nicosie il discute avec ses
salariés du plan de l'union européenne
qui a imposé une taxe sur les dépôts
bancaires
non je me sens juste l'union européenne
veut nous voler l'argent qu'on a mis
toute une vie a gagné alors ce sont donc
des témoignages de chypriotes diffusée
par toutes les télévisions européennes
avec nous sur ce plateau martin schulz
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le président
du parlement européen vous êtes un homme
fort de l'europe parce que le parlement
européen compte de plus en plus dans les
débats européens et dans les décisions
européennes
une question tout de suite donc sur
chypre est-ce que selon vous chypre
pourrait quitter la zone euro
non pas du tout il faut qu'on garde la
zone euro ensemble ne faut pas
sous-estimer la volonté des quelques qui
spécule qui mettent leur argent sur les
paris de l'éclatement de la zone euro
est un pays important que l'autre les
petits comme les grands il faut garder
l'union monétaire ensemble parce que dit
il a mis une fois de séparer un pays d
autres ils vont continuer prochain cible
sera l'espagne le portugal l'italie et c
est ça nous coûte cher donc nous avons
un intérêt commun de regarder l'union
monétaire ensemble il faut pas mais on
fait comment parce que si les chypriotes
ne veulent pas de cette taxe sur les
comptes
et si l'union européenne et en
particulier leur groupe ne veut pas
payer la totalité de ce qu'il faut pour
chypre la situation est bloquée comme on
fait moi il faut trouver un sortie main
sortie qui inclut des éléments alain
côté je comprends absolument les gens
que nous avons vu ici qui sont en colère
on ne peut pas laisser payer les petits
gens répétaient épargnants pour les
pertes et des grandes banques ça ne va
pas du tout c'était la raison pourquoi
il ya la directive adoptée ici au
parlement de garantie des dépôts jusqu'à
100000 euros à l'autre côté on comprend
les chypriotes qui ont des investisseurs
surtout russes mais aussi des autres
avec des grandes dépôt
avec des taux d'intérêt à leur profit
qui est incomparable plus haut qu'en
france ou en allemagne par exemple
mais ces gens à partir de son 1000 euros
on peut les imposer et laisser les
autres libre au dessous de son 1000
il faut que les chypriotes eux mêmes
trouver une solution pour contribuer
leurs 5 me à caumont éléphants c'est à
eux
mais imposer les riches plus que les
pauvres je crois ça c'est une question
de justice mais en fonctionnant
directement sur les comptes bancaires
est ce que un tabou n'a pas été levé oui
absolument et donjons si les gens oui
absolument
si les gens ont l'impression que leur
argent sur les banques les plus sûres
ça c'est certainement pas très
raisonnable donc c'était pas la décision
la plus raisonnable
comment vous et que vous qualifieriez
justement cette décision qui a été prise
ici à quelques jours à bruxelles
à 4 heures du matin à l'issue d'une nuit
très très compliqué comme d'habitude
chez nous c'est ce que le parlement
critiques moi je critique t depuis
toujours trop vite sous pression à huis
clos
en pleine nuit avec pression ça ne
fonctionne jamais c'est une erreur getty
qui était fait
alors ceux qui en ce qui concerne le la
garantie des dépôts et la contribution
il faut trouver une solution qui protège
les petits entreprises léman en
entreprise les petits épargnants et qui
pèse disons qu'ils mettent le poids des
contributions sur les épaules qui sont
plus forts vous vous le mettez à quel
niveau
c'est à dire à 100 millions 25000 euros
25000 euros
je sais c'est pas à moi d'en juger moi
j'ai dit tout d'abord le vingt cinq
mille
je crois qu'ils à chypre à vingt cinq
mille euros sur un compte bancaire dans
ce pays c'est le maximum
mais comme l'un des hommes a dit c'est
l'épargnant de l'épargné mans de toute
une vie on ne peut pas l'imposer
donc il faut trouver une formule qui est
très chypriote qui est appropriée aux
circonstances très spécifique dans ce
pays
mais une chose est claire nous avons une
directive européen pour la garantie des
dépôts il ne faut pas en touche et donc
pendant les jours qui viennent il faut
trouver une solution qui compte en
allant compter les intérêts des
chypriotes de garder leur système
financier
mais à l'autre côté on ne peut pas
demander des contribuables européens de
équilibrer les pertes des oligarques
russes
quand vous avez appris justement cette
décision qui avait été prise qu est ce
que vous êtes dit là on fait une erreur
sais pas vous mais qu'est-ce que vous
êtes dit je trouve que leur groupe a
créé une situation qui est un coup dur
pas seulement contre l'euro contre les
institutions européennes entièrement et
pour la zone euro la sommerau maintenant
on n'est pas en danger j'en suis sûr
mais ça montre de nouvelles de nouveau
nous avons une seule des économies avec
avec amon et commun avec une banque
centrale et 17 gouvernement qui décide à
l'unanimité ça ne fonctionne pas nous
avons besoin avait forme entière de
système d la gouvernance économique en
europe est ce que vous craignez ce sera
ma dernière question sur chypre à une
contagion ou est-ce que vous craignez
déjà que tout simplement la confiance du
consommateur de l'épargnant du déposant
européens soient remplies aujourd'hui
dix ans si nous ne pourrions pas
l'erreur fait pendant les big n est pas
seulement par leur groupe
il faut avouer que aussi le gouvernement
chypriote états membres de l'eurogroupe
s'est pas seulement les autres c'était
aussi les chypriotes qui ont insisté à
l'inclusion de péter hain par nyon
à à la contribution si on corrige ça
maintenant avec plus de justice sociale
et avec une contribution de super chypre
ou 17 milliard qui est fiable
on va sortir très vite de cette
irritation
mais j'espère que ça aura lieu sinon si
on n'arrive pas à si on si on n'arrive
pas on est certainement des turbulences
je crois des marchés financiers
attendent que la sommerau agi cohérent
alors il ya un deuxième dossier qui est
évidemment intéresse beaucoup ici au
niveau européen c'est celui de la syrie
a eu un sommet européen il ya quelques
jours ici à bruxelles et la france avec
françois hollande et la grande bretagne
a dit david cameron ont demandé la levée
de l'embargo sur les armes pour les
rebelles
je vous propose de regarder ce reportage
est ensuite votre opinion regarder et
voici la question syrienne qui s'impose
au menu du sommet européen
le dossier n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
mais quelques heures avant l'ouverture
des discussions
paris fait une annonce position que nous
avons prise avec françois hollande c'est
de demander la levée de l'embargo sur
les armes
dès son arrivée au conseil françois
hollande confirme la position française
la france considère aujourd'hui
en syrie des armes sont livrés au régime
de bachar al assad et notamment par les
russes nous nous souhaitons que les
européens lève l'embargo l'initiative
prend de court les partenaires européens
et le premier ministre britannique david
cameron est sur la même position
volontaire de la première heure en libye
paris et londres où prennent leur
responsabilité françois hollande et
moi-même nous sommes d'accord pour lever
l'embargo sur les armes en syrie parce
que cette mesure j'ai un traité de la
même manière le régime syrien et
l'opposition
seule la slovénie soutient la position
franco britannique la plupart des
partenaires allemagne en tête redoutent
que les armes ne tombent dans de
mauvaises mains
si l'armement des rebelles venaient
d'une coalition plus large de pays et
qu'il gagne en technologie cela pourrait
je pense rendre la situation encore plus
instable et surtout une fois que le
régime d'assad sera tombée ces armes se
répandrait dans le moyen-orient au sens
large et toute la région en serait
encore plus vite arisée est déstabilisé
depuis deux ans le conflit syrien passé
de la révolte à la guerre civile contre
le régime de bachar el-assad aurait fait
plus de soixante dix mille morts et plus
d'un million de réfugiés
alors martin schulz est ce que vous
comprenez ce changement de position de
la france en particulier
j'ai envie de vous dire mais quelle
mouche quelle mouche a quitté à
appliquer la france je comprends très
bien la les propositions françaises pour
le départ je ne suis pas moi-même je
suis réticent en ce qui concerne la
levée de l'embargo
parce qu'elle la coalition de
l'opposition et très incohérent et parmi
eux il ya aussi des forces avec lesquels
on ne peut pas coopérer
on a vu ça des islamistes les
intégristes on a vu ça en libye comment
ça se passe finalement à l'autre côté
derrière les propositions françaises
il y avait la pensée qu'il faut
augmenter la pression maximale sur
bachar al assad pour le montrer à long
terme du n'a pas de chance et je crois
que ça c'est aussi un motif derrière ces
propositions françaises mais vous êtes
quand même opposé clairement à la levée
de l'embargo
non je ne suis pas opposé du premier
moment
moi j'ai pris ça aussi avec une certaine
surprise que flamands d'érosion et
françois hollande n'a proposé un autre
côté je le comprends encore une fois il
faut qu'on augmente la pression et une
annonce manquant les v potentiel de
l'embargo des armes pourraient renforcer
l'opposition c'est un signal fort à
bachar al assad de dégager de bouger
dans toute façon et donc la proposition
était une proposition qui a animé un
débat politique qui je trouve
mais est ce que comme le dit françois
hollande le pire
enfin le risque le plus important ça
serait de ne rien faire et de laisser
faire
mais là il a tout à fait raison encore
une fois cette double annonce est un
message pour assad
mais à l'autre côté un message aussi
pour l'opposition il ya la france et la
grande bretagne qui proposent la lgv et
il ya les autres qui sont réticents et
ça ouvre aussi un créneau pour un débat
au sein de l'opposition pourquoi les
autres sont réticents et peut-être ça
mène aussi une clarification à
l'intérieur de l'opposition de se
débarrasser de ces éléments qui ne
contribue pas à la libération de pays
qui veulent remplacer un système
autoritaire par un autre pour lever
l'embargo sur les armes il faut
l'unanimité des états européens
vous croyez qu'il va y avoir un accord
j'espère toujours qu'il y à un accord
les préconditions je viens de les
détruire
c'est une clarification au sein aussi de
l'opposition
on peut augmenter la pression à
l'opposition de se libérer de ses forces
qui sont partis tout démocratique et je
crois le signalait si ça aura lieu il ya
peut-être aussi une possibilité pour
nous on les vit de l'embargo en fait
l'embargo pour l'instant se tient
jusqu'au 31 mai si la france et la
grande-bretagne décide unilatéralement
de livrer des armes aux rebelles syriens
vous trouvez que c'est un précédé vous
trouverez que c'est un précédent
dangereux
c'est certainement pas sans précédent
c'est peut-être il n'est pas dangereux
soyons honnêtes la politique extérieure
la politique de sécurité de l'union
européenne et sous développés nous avons
vu je reviens à la libye que l'union
européenne au conseil de sécurité a voté
dans les trois différentes directions
des impôts les autres contre les
allemands abstentions alors c'est pas un
précédent c'est malheureusement le cas
que les européens ont du mal de trouver
là des positions communes
donc si je résume bien votre position
vous êtes très prudent sur la levée de
cet embargo
plutôt contre mais si ça venait à se
faire même uniquement la grande bretagne
à la france ça ne serait pas si grave
que ça c'est une certaine normalité que
le 2e états membres de l'union
européenne qui sont en même temps des
forces veto du conseil sécurité agisse
des temps en temps un indépendant
tellement je ne souhaite pas ça mais je
suis réaliste je prends note de la
réalité merci beaucoup martine chose
d'avoir répondu à nos questions on va
maintenant partir de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée dans un instant kathia
gilder et son invité mais tout de suite
donc direction tunis avec un projet de
chaîne de télévision pour les femmes qui
est soutenu par l'union européenne
reportage à tunis signé ahmed tazir
remontés à bloc faiza majri cette
journaliste nous emmène pour une balade
dans le souk de tunis est ce que nous en
tunisie actuellement on a peur elle
interpelle le badaud interdit aux non
musulmans mais ça n'a pas de sens et
questionne les filles qu'elles croisent
garder les filles comme elles sont
jolies
regardez les filles de mon pays vous
êtes magnifique vous de toute beauté les
filles est ce que vous sentez qu'il ya
un problème dans le pays
oui oui et du problème quel est le
problème
est ce que vous vous faites agresser
quand vous êtes dans la vie on n'en est
pas encore à ce stade
qu'est ce que vous avez peur je voulais
dit on n'en est pas encore à ce stade
mais on a dû quand même des changements
au niveau vestimentaire plus de femmes
voilées
arrêtons de dire que nous sommes au bord
de la crise on va finir nous au bord de
la crise de nerf d'avoir une fausse
image de nous là où vous êtes
ce jour là des centaines de femmes
battent le pavé
l'ancien président bourguiba avait
accordé un statut des plus progressistes
aux femmes tunisiennes le plus abouti du
monde arabe
ces femmes ne veulent pas de ces acquis
soient remis en cause par les islamistes
pas plus loin qu'hier
anima m'a dit les femmes pour des
manifestations pour sortir une hutte
dans la rue donc rien que voir ça tu
imagines
c'est quoi la suite à la situation comme
toute révolution c'est une situation
ambiguë ça ne vient que de démarrer tout
le monde se recherche et l'opposition
qui cherche sa voie palais présidentiel
de carthage le chef de l'état moncef
marzouki célèbre la journée
internationale de la femme et quand on
lui demande si les acquis de la
tunisienne sont menacés aujourd'hui le
président s'énerve c'est de la foutaise
pure et simple jamais jamais les droits
de la femme n'ont été aussi respectés
jamais ils n'ont été aussi peu menacée
c'est tout simplement les gens qui
crient au loup au loup au loup alors que
le lou n'existe que dans leurs fantasmes
je peux vous assurer une chose que sait
ça relève de dénigrement et que ça
relève tout simplement de la mauvaise
foi ces gens là je les ai je l'air dit
taisez vous la femme justement l'objet
d'une conférence dans un hôtel huppé de
la capitale
je voudrais à présent vous présenter
brièvement le projet nice atterri il à
le faire et correspondant à bruxelles
pour plusieurs médias internationaux
elle a convié ses amis une ministre
finlandaise une députée européenne entre
autres elle est venue annoncer le
lancement dans un an de la première
chaîne de télévision dédiée aux femmes
du bassin méditerranéen
un pont jeté entre les deux rives inès
ayala sender est espagnol et député
européen
elle en est convaincu le projet ni sa tv
peut être financée grâce à l'aide d'une
fondation européenne pour la démocratie
pour le moment partira au tour de entre
12 et 14
millions d'euros essayer vraiment
d'aller vers les journalistes vers ces
initiatives et nissa tv je trouve que
entre autres font ça peut être justement
un des ces instruments dans nous voulons
pour ce genre de fondation si notre
député est optimiste laura baeza l'est
beaucoup moins
elle représente l'union européenne en
tunisie en période de crise
pas sûr que l'europe ait les moyens de
financer une télévision
pour l'instant elle a le support
politique de l'union européenne à un
très haut niveau ça veut dire madame
ashton n'a pas de ligne budgétaire qui
est passé qui ont été décidées pour les
atv pas un européen de la démocratie pas
encore y'a rien ni sa tv aurait pourtant
beaucoup à raconter
si elle avait existé la télévision
aurait certainement braqué ses caméras
vers le théâtre el hamra et son
spectacle monstre anna mousse d
enchantement après la révolution
la femme et son rêve voilée
voilà pour ce sujet signé ahmed tazir
réalisé à tunis et nous sommes revenus à
bruxelles nous sommes avec lila lefebvre
bonjour je vous remercie d'être avec
nous vous êtes le pilote si je puis dire
de ce projet la directrice du projet ni
sa tv alors cette chaîne vous avez fait
une conférence de presse ici à peu près
un an avec des députés européens le
projet a avancé depuis nice atv d'abord
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire est qu'elle
est la vocation de cette chaîne que vous
voulez faire naître alors comme son nom
l'indiqué ni cela veut dire femmes au
pluriel en france et women en anglais et
c'est une chaîne de télévision qui sera
dédié totalement aux femmes euro
méditerranéenne il faut dire que l'offre
des chaînes aujourd'hui des deux côtés
de la méditerranée et rive nord comme
rive sud
elles sont soit superficielles ou alors
archaïque
donc c'est un projet innovant c'est un
projet d'envergure sans précédent
la deuxième raison aussi pour laquelle
un jour je me suis réveillé et lever le
matin je me suis dit ah tiens pourquoi
pas une chaîne de télévision dédiée aux
femmes parce que tout simplement on n'en
parle pas il ya trop de stéréotypes de
part et d'autre de la méditerranée
et donc c'est une chaîne qui serait
dédié spécifiquement aux fans qui vise à
promouvoir la condition féminine mais
aussi peut-être les valeurs de la
démocratie dans ces pays qui ont connu
un printemps arabe qui aujourd'hui peut
être remis en question c'est ça le but
du projet aussi nice et tv n'est pas une
chaîne destinée aux pays du printemps
arabe ça il faut absolument que ce soit
clair c'est une chaîne de télévision les
la faune européenne et européennes et
méditerranéennes pays
et vous en particulier donné l'ancien
président français a appelé l'upm donc
l'union pour la méditerranée ceci
englobe 4 43 pays donc de la rive sud et
est de la méditerranée
plus les 27 pays y compris la nuit
romaine compris la turquie
oui forcément alors on voit vous avez
des soutiens politiques notamment ceux
madame catherine ashton la haute
représentante de l'ue pour la diplomatie
européenne
mais est-ce que vous avez l'argent
aujourd'hui ce que vous avez une ex de
la guerre le nerf de la guerre
nous avions renoncé nous avons en fait
des promesses
vous savez que vous évoquez à l'instant
kafana ashton elle est à l'initiative de
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le fonds
européen pour la démocratie
je pense que c'est un instrument qui
cadre très bien avec notre projet on
attend donc de recevoir un soutien il
existe ce fonds pour la démocratie il ya
des tas été pensé par café naz jetons en
2011 donc aux lendemains des printemps
arabes
aujourd'hui il est devenu une réalité et
nous espérons nous aspirons à recevoir
donc un soutien financier de l'union
européenne aussi autre chose de très
important
ni sa tv est ouverte à aux
investissements privés qu'on public de
part et d'autre de la méditerranée donc
ça n'est pas une chaîne européenne
financièrement comme on a essayé de le
dire lors de la conférence à tunis
les setting mars dernier mais nous
sommes ouverts donc aux investissements
arabes aux investissements sud
méditerranéen mais aussi de l'europe de
l'europe met alors en même temps
l'europe est en crise on le sait on le
dit on ne fait que de le dire dans cette
émission elle n'a pas d'argent les
discussions pour le sur le budget
européen se sont toujours en train de
suivre leurs cours dans dans la peine ya
beaucoup de programmes qui voient leur
fonte réduisent que vous n'êtes pas est
ce que vous n'avez pas d inquiétude
qu'est ce qui vous fait penser que les
européens vont privilégier votre projet
qui sur le papier est très beau
effectivement mais qui si l'on peut
penser qu'ils vont privilégier votre
projet plutôt qu'un autre
très bonne question il faut aussi en
période de crise
effectivement il faut aussi en même
temps que l'union européenne et les
moyens de sa politique
vous savez ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
la nouvelle politique européenne de
voisinage qui est pour moi une sorte
d'investissement
si on parle que du sud de la
méditerranée elle s'était engagée à
réaliser des investissements dans cette
région là du monde ça vous dit
absolument s'est engagé de soutenir
toute une série de programmes notamment
sur le plan économique mais pas
seulement sur le plan de la démocratie
vous le savez sur elle compte maintenant
énormément sur la société civile de des
pays du sud des pays du printemps arabe
et donc j'imagine qu'elle va tenir assez
assez assez promesses en revenant dans
l'un des pays berceau du printemps arabe
la tunisie
nous avons interrogé la vice présidente
de l'assemblée nationale tunisienne qui
s'exprime notamment sur la question du
voile écouter ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
dit
j'ai côtoyé tellement de femmes
habillées de tellement de façons ça
riboud beau polar jus cours du plan qu
il s'agit pas de la longueur de la jupe
ou bien de la couleur de fichu sur la
tête
il s'agit de ce que nous portons comme
idée ce que nous faisons comme action et
comment on se voit dont la société dont
la famille comme actrice alors lille
est-ce que vous pensez que nous même de
ce côté ci de la méditerranée avons un
regard voilé si je puis dire sur la
femme l'image de la femme
méditerranéenne
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
stéréotypes il ya beaucoup de craintes
et justement un des rôles de nissa tv
serait de transformer cette crainte
irraisonnée en une curiosité ce n est
pour aller dans les extrêmes
très souvent les gens du nord pense que
la femme du sud c'est la femme qui
portait un niqab et qui est interdite de
conduire une voiture et les gens du sud
pensent que la femme du nord
elle est en string et elle pose sur un
capot de voiture string d'un côté le
voile de l'autre c'est contre ce genre
de stéréotypes que vous voulez lutter
notamment avec votre chaîne mais ce que
vous êtes prête dans votre futur
rédaction si elle voit le jour
d'accepter que des femmes voilées
puissent travailler avec vous bah oui a
pas d'exclusion à léo elle sera ouverte
à tout pour cela que le voile se voyait
bien madame bâ dit je pense madame badi
qui est une femme voilée mais vraiment
dans le sentiment d'être une féministe
donc il faut arrêter ces jugements il
faut arrêter de juger avant de savoir
il ya des on n'exclut personne la femme
voilée la femme dévoilée la femme noire
la femme blanche
la femme musulmane la femme chrétienne
la femme laïque la femme athée toutes
les femmes se rend donc mis en avant
dans les chats tv alors on voit qu'en
tunisie en égypte d'endetter comme sale
la condition de la ddt de la famille est
un peu mise en cause quand est ce que
vous même vous vous inquiéter
pour le respect des droits de la femme
notamment dans ces pays-là inquiète
absolument
il faut il faut être là justement pour
montrer et pour dire que les droits de
la femme au même titre que les droits de
l'homme l'homme avec un petit h doivent
aussi être respectées
oui on est un petit peu inquiet mais
nous journalistes d'abord on est là
aussi pour le dire très haut et pour le
montrer
donc avec ce projet disent atterrés ce
sera aussi une priorité pour l'emploi
pour la formation absolument initiative
est aussi chacun c'est un projet
économique
on va recréer de l'emploi de part et
d'autre de la méditerranée
oui et bien très bien merci d'avoir nous
avoir expliqué ce projet ni sa tv qu'on
va à suivre en vous souhaitant bonne
chance merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous il a le verbe et moi je vous donne
rendez vous la semaine prochaine
ici même à bruxelles au coeur du
parlement européen avec françois vos
données pour une nouvelle émission de
rentrée au très bon site de programmes
sur les chaînes parlementaires va
bon